also Bobby Hunter is not to brag but he
told us who Banks he is so it's pretty
cool yeah who knows that was pretty cool
knows who banked using he told us oh
wait no for real
[Music]
this story
um got sent to me by Norman Lai the
Sneakers Bar dude yeah and I was gonna
have him come by and do it but he uh
he's flying out somewhere today so I'm
gonna just do it and [ __ ] it up but yeah
it's a pretty crazy thing in Memphis
again a lot of shit's going on in
Memphis Elvis um yeah thanks Elvis these
um thieves they basically broke in to 20
like big rig trailers
and stole eight hundred thousand dollars
worth of unreleased Nikes unreleased
Nikes how do they know [ __ ]
sneaker heads man they just yeah they
know yeah damn that's crazy Nike
Warehouse was in Oregon
all right yes HQ pretty sure they have
dishes it's not where everything is
there
the ones with the unreleased ones that's
pretty crazy yeah I like
I like it was at the Nike Factory just
making Nike shoes and the Nike Oompa
Loompas are just Cambodian kids oh man
yeah so he um he said isn't that right
Anthony
uh is it in the article
[Laughter]
so yeah after
um
the shirt bro it just seems like oh my
God
yeah so uh because of that all these all
these Nike started showing up on like
offer up and like these new news dude so
if you just feel like in the circulation
now like trying to be independently like
sold and fenced everywhere so uh let's
get some yeah let's buy some stockx you
know the website where you get it or
yeah they put
um they basically put a hold on you
can't buy or sell that shoe on the
that's how big stock actually well yeah
stock is they're not trying to get
[ __ ] so oh yeah but offer UPS like
third-party [ __ ] yeah we don't like the
[ __ ] let's talk local right yeah you'll
get all these like new accounts popping
up because if it's a [ __ ] new account
then obviously and then they'll be like
oh I got this I only got these size
don't ask for any other [ __ ] just these
sizes Craigslist is pretty good for
stolen property too yeah a lot of the
times eBay too are there images of what
these uh unreleased things look like
yeah yeah are they fire
I don't even know if these are the
unreleased because like there are
unreleased in there but not everything
in those in those that's crazy because I
thought they guarded like the unreleased
to like gold I know you would think
right you guys have unreleased Kendra's
merch
uh on Alibaba
unless but other people have released
[Laughter]
Jordan 11.
oh [ __ ] that's a wow that's got to be
crazy yeah that's true is that a good
shoe that's like Christmas that's like a
Christmas song big drop and then it says
that the only shoes that they left
behind were the air seshes um yeah and
since he left them one behind in clear
plastic
I don't know how you guys feel about it
I left them better than they found them
did you see the air quest in there or
did that
it almost lost his hat dude
dude so wood blocking this here did we
ask him if he's heard of the air sash or
something yeah that's your [ __ ] yeah
he never heard about what we said what
was I think it was Steve but they were
like
um you know there's a shoe at Nike that
looks very similar to yours you should
check them out and I think they stole
your style I think you should [ __ ] oh
yes it feels like you should send him a
cease and desist
whatever like full metal jacket and all
this I never even met this full body
language I [ __ ] respect the [ __ ] out
of them I know now I just know that he
just knows [ __ ] about me out there yeah
he knows a lot of true things he spoke a
lot of truths
yeah the uh and then the metallic silver
Air Jordan six as well
you like those I don't wear Jordans
except for the golf shoes because
they're more affordable did you guys
ever collect shoes and resell and all
that did you get into it never got into
that I liked the Air Force Ones Nike Air
Force ones are [ __ ] dope what color
are you all black I actually have these
ones that are like like black but
there's cyan on them too and I'm it
looks sick that's probably my favorite
shoe though you don't have Air Force
Ones man you're wearing a [ __ ] Amazon
onesie right now dude
just for that just for that I'm gonna
report another Kinte's video for
terrorism
another one just for that
oh he did it right there I don't think
these are actually pictures of the
stolen shoes but there are a bunch of
people doing hosts like I mean these are
some of the offer up ads and then uh
like those are the cherries right there
yeah it's just a shitload of boxes damn
bro sneaker heads also have that many
shoes too like as Norman showed us like
that Dude Looks Like A store himself
yeah I don't think Norman's a real
Sneakerhead dude I'm gonna say it he
didn't know who Fran Elations were
congratulations you know what he did say
that he's not as much of a sneaker hit
as he is a businessman and I [ __ ]
knew it dude he's more on the he's more
like a like a Chinese business dude than
he is like a shoe obsessed guy he's
probably he's like these are good
margins not really like oh I know every
single thing about this he's just a
[ __ ] smart guy yeah yeah that's why
he's got a bowling alley that's too bad
he doesn't know Fran Elations dude I
thought I made it I still don't know
foreign
you worked with what's his name when you
did the air size you worked with Walt
Disney ventilations what was the Tinker
Hatfield the OG OG yeah Hatfield who
also probably might know
do you know friend alicians or Anthony
you should tell them what what are
friend relations what are friends
Revelations is a OG like shoe review and
curator guy so like when new shoes would
pop out like he would give people like
the info on it is a person
and now he's been crushing like the nft
game a word also Bobby Hunters not to
brag but he told us who Banks he is so
it's pretty cool
that was pretty cool knows who Banks use
and he told us oh wait no for real he
says they play golf together yep but he
said you could just look at him he's
like but he forgot to point it out
before we oh I forgot to show him and
then ask him he said that if you watch
the the video of when they shredded in
the auction you know where his thing
shredded he said he's just the old he
said he's the gray-haired like dudes
like one of the old white guys there his
name is Billy Jason apparently Billy
Jason
yeah yeah he told us he said his name
remember because we were we thought it
was funny that he had two first names
yeah oh we'll call him a nerd for it was
that off camera or on camera it was off
camera oh [ __ ] sneak peek dude Jason
you're [ __ ] Banksy and we know it
dude we're on you [ __ ] we know
it probably we know who you are yeah
they're like when he said hundreds like
Warehouse was right next to where they
would Bank these Warehouse was at one
point
pretty sick huh Billy Jason dude really
Jason that's two Power Rangers right
there Billy Jason two Power Rangers
Billy Jackson Thomas yeah is it actually
it's not Trini Kimberly Billy Jason Zach
Zed dude
Alpha Zordon
shoe collections at all or no I have
like probably four pairs of shoes I feel
like you got a lot of nice shoes I got a
definitely I'm I definitely toned down
but definitely at one point I was
probably rocking like 50 pairs of shoes
that like and like 20 of them I never
even wore one you like love Adidas huh
just yeah I have so much Adidas honestly
I love it
and DC's baby I only liked Reeboks and
pumas when I was like trying to like
hell a break heart I think you also like
uh nah New Balance too right
I thought you like I thought you look
kids you guys are talking like I got
some multi-million dollar secret deal
with Nike and [ __ ] like that you're Nike
down right now like you're gonna break
his deal yeah he's gonna ruin it like
you don't even like send me free [ __ ] I
get free [ __ ] from other people don't
send this video to Nike don't send it
don't send the info at Nike these for
free hey oh wow
how'd you get those for free teaching in
Turkey
you already [ __ ] it up that much
you're just a turkey two weeks ago yeah
teaching like you're dancing you're
using your feet a lot were you teaching
the kids who are making your shoes for
you oh yeah yeah that's Asia Steve I
don't know where turkey is the air
Cambodia actually turkey is in Asia as
well it used to be called Asia Minor
yeah actually I did I did a thing where
uh only in Istanbul is the only place in
the world where on one Bridge we were in
European Istanbul and then as you drive
it you cross into Asia Istanbul that's
cool what's the difference
they're two different continents Europe
and Asia
what's I mean what's Europe Istanbul and
Asia Istanbul no it's literally just
like uh it's like St Louis Missouri
where it's like St Louis [ __ ] you're
in one State or the other state yes but
continents but within Istanbul oh here I
really it only I stumbled to
you know the other one you go to it but
stumble you only have stumbled to like
it just stop [ __ ] you know I don't
understand how like so you got like this
place where these um shipping containers
are coming through and they're like the
company's like oh we didn't sorry we
didn't have surveillance video for the
back lot just the front it's our job but
like with how [ __ ] easy it is to have
ring and nests like how are these
companies with massive I thought Nike's
doing it with [ __ ] ring cam you don't
think no but like the accessibility to
have to monitor any given Zone at
anything it sounds like an inside job
sounds like an inside job well the
cameras were off
the security guard that was working at
the Epstein jail he was so embarrassed
he started working here at the Nike
warehouse and then it happened again and
now he has to work somewhere else he's
the guy in charge of the camera I like
how stupid this room is that we think
that the Nike CEO gets like a ring
notification
oh I'm very busy yeah just do it this
wasn't stolen at Nike plus it they took
it from like basically like where the
shipping stuff goes like a [ __ ] uh
what do you call it those that
fulfillment fulfillment [ __ ]
fulfillment see that's what we should go
do we should just go check out these and
open them up he has like a lot of [ __ ]
going through you would think they would
watch the back
live that just sounds so stupid you know
what I think they should have done what
what Joe hit up Chris's dad been like yo
FedEx man I know you guys don't really
lose packages can you hook us up you
guys have a great track record FedEx why
are they working with there's they got
all this money why are they working with
a company no one knows about hey Chris
if you lose a package do you have a sick
hookup and your dad's just like I know
my whole family works at FedEx see
really my dad my mom my sister my
brother at one point wow my guys are
like the Walton family yeah you get the
deals like if you want to send some [ __ ]
well they'll be like get discount I get
my package before I buy it it comes
right there so it's like Amazon now yeah
for you we're on point with it they're
going to be social shipping I'm the only
one who hasn't worked for FedEx and I've
made that a point like I didn't have the
failure of the family or like no it's
not a failure I just is it's just always
been a like uh like yo just get a job at
FedEx like a lot anybody can get a job
at FedEx bro don't say it like that why
are you downplaying it bro like like a
couple hours ago it's not like USPS
where you actually have to work like
FedEx is like yeah anyone can get a job
it always it always came off as like
when I when I moved out here to La it
was one of those like uh like a safety
net go get a job look at the coal mine
and I'm like nah I wanted to feel the
the hustle the like want to feel that
grind I didn't want to go there's some
Grinders I didn't want it to be easy
like I'll just get I'll work at FedEx
and have that safety net I was like nah
cool that's why I have that I think if
you're gonna work at FedEx though don't
work at the shipping side work at the
Kinko side yeah the Kinkos it's a little
bit more FedEx office retail shops I
print a lot of papers more respectable
because you [ __ ] come in and you help
people with their business papers hella
benefits though it's actually it's
pretty dope working for FedEx hella
benefits the flight benefits your
family's good and anyone can get a job
yeah
flight benefits you get free flights and
[ __ ] like you just are you in the FedEx
[ __ ] plane
no it's all just like stamped by stuff
but I mean cheap and you're like because
I was under my uh like my parents uh
like flight benefits until I was 26.
so I was able to yeah
have you ever lost a package with FedEx
no oh see stand corrected doing good
foreign
[Music]